[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
me acompaña en el estudio mar Romero
sala Mara bienvenida buena mañana de
lunes y también feliz aniversario
tenemos dos motivos para celebrar el
primero en un año de nuestra matinal de
directo América y cinco años de Francia
24 en español del mar así Raúl cumplimos
un año ya trabajando en esta mesa Y
quería aprovechar para decirte que es un
gusto encantado también madre trabajar
contigo pero vamos a hablar de la
materia que vamos una noticia muy
importante el día de hoy la frontera
entre Colombia y Venezuela porque su
reapertura también tiene muchos impactos
sobre por supuesto la salud de las
personas de lado y lado Pues así es Raúl
no hay varios problemas como comentabas
y Sabemos que esta frontera es
determinante en la vida de las personas
de muchas formas así esté cerrada o así
esté abierta no por ejemplo durante todo
el tiempo que la frontera estuvo cerrada
que no había ni siquiera pasó peatonal
que no fue hace tanto tiempo se
convirtió en una línea de contrabando de
muchísimos medicamentos a los cuales no
se acceden en Venezuela y que en cambio
accesibles en Colombia incluso ya cuando
se abrió y cuando ya estábamos en la
fase esta del paso peatonal pues era uno
a punto de Mercado negro de venezolanos
muchos venezolanos buscando eso como
decíamos acceder a medicamentos por
otros precios que no se pueden encontrar
en el lado venezolano de la frontera sin
embargo pues esto era una situación
bastante preocupante de hecho hace
relativamente pocas semanas la
asociación de farmacéuticos venezolanos
denunciaba que muchos de estos
medicamentos que se consiguen a través
de esta venta fronteriza poco regulada
pues no son seguros precisamente por la
poca regulación que existe pueden pasar
dos cosas no por un lado que el
medicamento esté adulterado es decir que
no sea lo que se está vendiendo por otro
lado también que estos medicamentos no
hayan tenido las condiciones adecuadas
para mantenerse en buenas condiciones y
que por lo tanto Pues a través de pues
no haberse mantenido la cadena de frío
que hay al desarrollo exposición al sol
la exposición a la lluvia pues no
funcione no intentes a la vida varios
casos en estas zonas fronterizas donde
los medicamentos o no hacen nada o
incluso les ha sentado las personas mar
en la actualidad la situación de acceso
a los fármacos en Venezuela Pues hay dos
problemas no básicamente el primero es
el precio y el segundo es el
abastecimiento hemos hecho un ejercicio
para entender cómo es esta situación
hemos revisado en una de las principales
distribuidoras de medicamentos que
distribuyen tanto en Colombia como en
Venezuela cuánto cuesta para tratar uno
un resfriador un expectorante un
Paracetamol y un descongestionante tres
productos muy básicos y vemos que en un
caso pues cuesta más o menos 85
bolívares que equivale a 10 dólares y en
el caso de Colombia 60000 que es
aproximadamente unos 12 también dólares
la diferencia no es tanta pero sí coge
una relevancia distinta cuando lo
comparamos con el salario pues básico
mensual medio digamos de las situaciones
no en Venezuela son 118 dólares en
Colombia 362 digamos que más allá de la
lógica de Que obviamente nadie va a
comprar 12 veces de estos packs de
medicamentos así funciona no en
Venezuela tiene un salario medio que le
permite comprar 12 medicamentos estas
dificultades se reflejan mar en la vida
cotidiana de los venezolanos por
supuesto claro es que los medicamentos
no es lo único no también hay otros
problemas que es por ejemplo el
abastecimiento de insumos básicos para
los hospitales a raíz del bloqueo
económico que rodea Venezuela pero
también pues de los problemas económicos
que atraviesa el país y hay varios
hospitales que tienen problemas para
tratar a sus pacientes un gran ejemplo
por ejemplo es cuando hablamos de
enfermedades crónicas como problemas de
riñón y le de la diálisis que necesitan
esto estos pacientes que tienen que
acceder a tratamientos como la diálisis
que necesitan de esta maquinaria que es
difícil reparar que sufren a veces de
problemas de apagones Entonces tenemos
todos estos problemas que dificultan
pues el acceso a tratamientos
literalmente básicos para salvarle la
vida a las personas en Venezuela y por
eso también queríamos traer a colación
un reportaje de la agencia francesa afp
que hace unas semanas Pues hablaban con
uno de estos pacientes
necesitaban diálisis y comentaba un poco
su situación se trata de Jaime
villamizar escuchemoslo
realmente
estamos esperando a ver si si se busca
de solucionar esto como da esto porque
Oye oye Cuántas personas hay que no
alcanza con con esos centros
yo no eso no no da bastos En que hace eh
No miles miles y miles y miles de
diálisis mar y también en las
dificultades alrededor de todo el acceso
a la salud a los medicamentos son una de
las principales motivaciones para migrar
muchos venezolanos o no que se encuentra
cuando llegan a Colombia claro estamos
hablando de personas que emigran tanto
para acceder personalmente a los
tratamientos como personas que emigran
para poder financiar los tratamientos de
sus familiares o amigos que quedan del
lado venezolano hay muchos como decíamos
que cruzan a Colombia buscando
precisamente esta mejor acceso a los
servicios de la salud pero hay un
problema y es que sin estar
regularizados no pueden acceder a los
servicios públicos de salud entonces
recordemos que en abril de 2021 el
presidente el ex presidente Duque
anunció un programa de regularización
que ahora ya lleva más de un año y medio
un año y medio de después vemos que los
permisos aprobados de más de dos
millones dos millones a 300.000 Casi más
de hecho de migrantes venezolanos
registrados el 51% se les han aprobado
el permiso y los que realmente están
entregado los que ya son efectivos no
llegan ni siquiera la mitad desde el 42%
un millón de permisos entonces que eso
quiere decir que más de la mitad de los
venezolanos que están ahora mismo en
Colombia no tienen acceso a los
servicios básicos de salud todo esto sin
además mencionar pues las
discriminaciones las trabas burocráticas
a las que a veces también se pueden
enfrentar por ejemplo han habido casos
de venezolanos a quienes les piden los
papeles para acceder perdón a servicios
de emergencia y eso sabemos Pues que es
totalmente ilegal los servicios de
emergencias tienen que ser públicos
accesibles para todas las personas
entonces pues bueno sabemos que de un
lado de la frontera la situación no es
fácil pero es que de este lado del lado
colombiano tampoco lo Es mar como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud mañana Por supuesto
más salud en directo América de Francia
24 felices por este primer año de
programa Felicidades Raúl